la discipline c'est une tradition ici
jusqu'à la devise des Jésuites l'élève
est comme un cadavre dans la main du
maître la récré est fini 12 millions
d'élèves 700000 profs et un STI vont à
l'école c'est si j'ose dire le
chevèement de la rentrée difficile à
oublier d'autant que nous avons assisté
à ça
regardez
[Applaudissements]
pas commode la prof ça nous a donné
envie d'aller voir ce qui se passe dans
les écoles publiques et privées un petit
tour dans les lycées professionnels où
ce n'est pas la joie sa chôe dur à la
sortie une visite aux professeurs qui ne
sont pas tous très chauds d'apprendre la
Marseillaise aux enfants de la patrie et
puis le rush vers l'école privée 4 %
d'élèves en plus et vous verrez que ce
ne sont pas les enfants des riches qui
s'y bousculent allons maintenant tous en
rang c'est la
rentrée
actement allô oui vous m'ave dit une
inscription en classe de
4eou comment s'appelle
l'enfant lorsque l'ignement public a
échoué se tourne vers l'enseignement
privé au Collège de l'Assomption les
demandes d'inscription affluent par
centaines c'est dans le second cycle de
la 6e à la 3è que le phénomène est le
plus fort à l'âge où tous les problèmes
se télescopent échec scolaire
orientation crise de l'adolescence des
armé inquiè ces familles exposent les
mêmes Grif et cherchent les mêmes
remèdes qu'estce que vous attendez du
collège et bien nous attendons du
sérieux et une une continuité dans le
travail et non pas une méthode
désordonnée telle qu'elle existe
actuellement dans le collège où se
trouve cet enfant quand un enfant de 12
ans qui est en 4e c'est exactement je ne
généralise pas tous les professeurs mais
c'est qu'il a ceci à faire cela à faire
et que tout est contrôlé et bien il est
évident qu'un enfant arrive à à s'en
sortir un travail régulier suivi mais
encore une fois disons un enfant
canalisé canalisé
voilà
rigueur discipline ces TR mots nous les
avons retrouvés dans la plupart des
dossiers certaines demandes allant
jusqu'à solliciter une véritable prise
en charge l'enseignement public est
qualifié de laxiste et des parents lui
tournent le dos dès l'entrée en
6e j'aimerais que ma fille a une autre
éducation et que je puisse la choisir
moi
c'estàdd une éducation plus plus
rigoureuse et que je sache où elle est à
n'importe quel moment de la journée
c'estàdire à l'école parce que le
problème qu'il y a justement dans le
laïque à partir du collège c'est que
bien souvent quand il y a des absences
de professeurs pour une raison pour une
autre les enfants sont dans la rue les
craintes de Monsieur Oriol Carole en est
l'illustration d'échec en échec à 15 ans
elle redouble sa
5è désorienté elle espère trouver ici le
moyen de reprendre
pied
alors vous avez souhaité inscrire Carole
au collège
pourquoi soit un plus au lycée je sais
pas si ça va pas qu'on me fe appeler
qu'on discute avec elle que ce soit un
peu plus familial je pense dans le priv
c'est pe plus comme ça plus
pr souvent livr ellemême Carole vient
retrouver ses amis des jeunes qui pour
la plupart ont déjà abandonné l'école
carole a réalisé qu'elle souhaite pour
elle un avenir
différent dans l'établissement où je
suis si l'an prochain je retourne ça
sera pareil quoi je travaillerai pas tu
rends responsable le collège public de
fait de ne pas travailler non non non
c'est c'est à cause de moi parce que
suffit que dans la classe il y en a deux
ou tro qui qui rigole après on a envie
de suivre et on on se fait entraîner et
on fait plus rien alors que je pense que
dans un collège privé tout le monde a
l'esprit travailleur et on
obligatoirement on est obligé de suivre
et on travailleo vous vous sentez
actuellement désarmé face à à cette
situation là moi je me sens un peu
désarmé oui bon le fait de d'être seulle
avec elle aussi
peut-être de manquer de soutien de bon
je sais je le trouve pas je le trouve
pas à
l'école donc c'est sûr je me sens
désarmé hein vous espérez le trouver
dans j'espère disons que j'espère
qu'elle sera un peu plus tenue donc
moins moins dans la rue je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que ce
sera je sais pas si ça va être bon j'en
sais rien je le saai à la fin de l'année
prochaine disons que bon on essaie on
essaie autre chose il y a autre chose on
essae c'est toi qui après la décision de
changer ça
h pourquoi tu prends cette
décision parce que c'est tout tout mon
avenir qui suit si je me réveille pas
maintenant reste un obstacle à ce
changement l'argent l'école privée
payante c'est vrai mais elle s adapté à
la demande et ouvre plus largement ses
portes pour Carole les études ici seront
gratuites comme pour 17 élèves sur 700
votre participation aux charges de
fonctionnement du collège seront lié à
un choix que vous allez faire vous allez
choisir une contribution familial en
fonction de vos possibilités financières
c'est moins cher que ce que vous pensez
d'abord c'est cher quand on a des petits
revenus je croyais que c'était bien plus
cher que ça tout à fait et puis bon je
suis allé voir le cadre c'estàd l'école
où je la mettais bon ça m'a paru
bien en plus maintenant les écoles
libres je sais pas avant si ça existait
il passe un contrat éducatif qu's
appellent c'estàd ils vous disent
comment ça va marcher ce qu'il vont
faireu pr le contrat que parents et
enfants signent et s'engage à respecter
comporte trois proposition acquérir le
savoir accepter la discipline mais aussi
approfondir la foi chrétienne les par à
vous nêtre guerre attiré par la
dimension religieuse en réponse l'école
qui le sait se montre discrète et le
fait que ça soit un établissement de
l'enseignement catholique moi j'ai fait
toutes mes études chez les Dominicaines
bon c'est pas c'est pas votre motivation
première c'est pas ma motivation
première mais bon moi je trouve ça très
bien h voilà donc
et et etou qu'est-ce qu'il en
pense rien de spécial rien de spécial
oui il va se retrouver dans
établissement catholique il y aura de la
catéchèse par exemple vous pensez que
vous serez en accord avec tout ce qui
vous sera appris sur l'éducation
religieuse euh c'est peêre pas toujours
évident parce que bon je vous dis moi je
suis catholique mais bon pratiquant on a
touours le temps de pratiquer si
vraiment on veut moi je pratique pas je
reconnais mais enfin je vous dis pour
une fille il me semble que c'est plus
important que pour un garçon
l'éducation surtout par les temp qui
[Musique]
courant tous ces gens viennent et
exposent un certain de problèmes ça va
des problèmes scolaires au problème de
discipline vous avez des solutions à
tous ces problèmes oh nous n'avons pas
de solution à tous les problèmes il y a
des échecs nous passons un contrat avec
les parents nous essayons de le
respecter mais il est évident que la
pièce maîtresse là-dedans c'est aussi
l'enfant vous leur laissez croire que
vous pouvez répondre à tout ça je ne
pense pas que nous laissons croire nous
indiquons que nous allons essayer
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'un enfant en
situation d'échec nous allons essayer
d'apporter notre aide à la famille mais
la famille joue aussi un rôle important
faut quand même pas oublier que les
parents sont les premiers responsables
de l'éducation de l'enfant et ce qui se
fait à l'école ne peut pas tout
régler au milieu d'un parc sur une
colline autour d'un château c'est le
lycée Bellevue et son collège l'école
publique et laïque celle de la
République au milieu d'un parc sur une
autre colline et autour d'une maison aux
alures de monastère l'école du Caou une
école privée et catholique contrairement
aux apparences et au paysages un monde
sépare ces deux établissements que
fréquentent des milliers d'élèves de la
6e à la
terminale nous avons demandé à deux
élèves de 3e de nous raconter leur école
à leur
façon bon mais je m'appelle Sylvie et je
suis en 3e à
belleevue et puis voilà il s'appelle
Olivier il est au Kaosu chez les
jésuites une école de curé comme on dit
et même un internat pour certains mais
depuis longtemps le kaouu a modernisé
son look de pensionnat il y a aussi des
externes comme Olivier je préfère et
être externe et rentrer chez moi t tous
les soirs et tous les midis pour être
plus libre tu sais comment se passe la
vie des pensionnaire ici je sais qu'ils
ont 2 heures d'études obligatoirees à
peu près
et après la classe une récréation et
ensuite le dîner et après il doivent
aller se se coucher je pense le soir je
préfère être chez moi travailler quand
j'en ai envie
et pouvoir me distraire à l'heure où
j'en ai envie aussi pensionnaire on n
jamais avec sa famille on est seul avec
ses amis c'est
tout Olivier n'est pas interne mais il
n'est pas pour autant livré à lui-même
le casouou c'est un lycée plus quelque
chose d'autre j'ai toujours été je
connais pas les autres lycées dans le
clège Ju bon il y a il y a eu des des
heures de catéchèes il y a des
célébrations
qui qui sont qui sont célébrés bon le
mardi entre entre MIDH et 2h
ou tout le monde est libre d'y aller il
on peut rencontrer un prêtre quand on a
[Applaudissements]
besoin
[Musique]
bonjourtoi alors comment
ça le lycée Bellevue un immense campus à
l'américaine presque une expérience
pédagogique celle de la liberté pour les
grands et même les plus
jeunes non non je suis pas au courant du
règlement antérieur bon je je sais
quelques quelques passages mais sans
plus mais tu devrais on peut pas vivre
sans connaître le règlement oh ça gêne
pas on peut vivre sans connaître le
règlement pour l'instant ça m'a P gé de
pas le connaître le conseiller principal
d'éducation autrefois on disait le
Surget son bureau s'appelle la vie
scolaire on y frise l'autogestion les
élèves classent même les mots d'excuse
dès que les parents ont rempli le petit
mot chaque élève a un dossier un dossier
voyez-vous un dossier il y en a 760 ici
qui sont rangés dans lequel dans chaque
dossier vous avez à peu près toute la
comptabilité des absences qui sont
faites par élèv tout simplement voilà ça
fait beaucoup çaélève non B il y en a
qui sont de santé plus fragile que
d'autres oui bien sûr il y en a qui ont
du mal à se réveiller aussi il y en a
d'autres les la mobilette souvent
P mais quand je vois des élèves qui
vraiment exagère trop je pense que 4 ou
5 he de col ça ferait pas de mal que je
et après je crois pas qu'il recommencé
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire exagér bon
par exemple
réfectoire C les ver
exprès LAN nourriture partout là il
exagè vous avez bien entendu c'est une
élève de 15 ans qui réclame des heures
de col au collège
bell-evue mais en croire Olivier ici au
couou pas besoin de réclamer le Surget
que certains surnomment le shérif a des
yeux derrière la tête rien ne lui
échappe il aime ses élèves mais il a des
principes une convocation au bureau
c'est la sainte trouille assurée pour
les concres et les
[Applaudissements]
chahuteurs peur non je pense pas il me
craignent il me craignent mais
peur bon il arrive que j'en
convoque je crois que sans discipline ce
serait beaucoup plus difficile et
beaucoup moins agréable pour eux de
vivre ici et pour nous aussi d'ailleurs
c'est une sorte de jeu ou d'ailleurs
l'expression que que je leur donne en
début d'année c'est jouer le
jeu alors il y a une sction sous forme
d'avertissement on a une page sur un
cahier et le surveillant écrit le motif
motif c'est gêne la classe fait du bruit
euh traî dans les couloirs enfin au bout
de trois avertissements on a on a 2
heures de retenue le mercredi après-midi
ou le samedi matin chaque élève a
beaucoup de sanctions à la fin de
l'année où allez-vous
mademoiselle vous avez prévenu le
surveillant il fait pas peur mais il est
il est sévère il prend beaucoup de
sanction prend beaucoup de mesures pour
que on reste calme qu'on respecte les
consignes la discipline c'est une
tradition ici jusqu'à la devise des
Jésuites l'élève est comme un cadavre
dans la main du maître je vais être très
direct je vais vous dire seulement si cû
à cadaver est-ce que c'est toujours
vrai je ne sais pas trop si ça a été
vrai d'une part parce
que un cadavre de toute façon ne peut
plus rien faire il n'a plus de
personnalité c'est tout ce qui reste
d'un être qui a vécu alors qu'ici nous
nous occupons de jeunes d'êtes vivants
qui vont essayer de devenir des adultes
et en tout cas pas des cadavres ce que
je voulais dire par là c'est que en fait
école privée école d'élite on a
l'impression en rencontrant certains des
élèves ici que c'est quand même un petit
peu de la la matière molle un peu
malléable qui qui sert à faire sûrement
de brillant sujets mais en tout cas qui
n'ont pas une grosse grosse
[Musique]
personnalité la personnalité c'est
quelque chose qui s'acquiert petit à
petit dans une communauté de vie à force
de se frotter aux réalités de la vie
alors si vous pensez que ce sont des
enfants ici qui sont un peu à l'écart
dans un cocon
privilégié c'est possible mais il n'y a
pas que ça ceux qui bouffent encore du
curé les républicains enendurc
trouveront sans doute qu'on brise les
vol
che jéses à BEVUE r nouvel ordre les
élèves et les professeurs discutent des
problèmes mon avis il y a moins de
discipline on fait plus de concertation
et les enfants participent plus à la vie
de l'établissement et à la communauté
éducative on a l'impression de ne pas
être de chaque côté de la barrière on
est tous concernés par la vie de
l'établissement les enfants vousont les
adolescents diront de sentir concern les
concern
ce n'est pas un enclot donc partout les
enfants se sent un peu plus
libre et puis nous avons des rapports
comm des
copains non c'est pas possible nos
rapport ne paspp de copinage ou même des
rapports alors chacun essaie de rester à
sa place mais de faire son
devoir évidemment ça n'est pas si simple
surtout à 15 ans de faire devoir à
l'école et s devoir à la maison alors
parfois onrap mais syv est
indulgente de
Mobage mais c'est pas la dé
profonde début Contin comme ça
Aron
ou de l'éleque ivier de l'école privé
ont tous deux en commun qu'ils aiment le
école même sil la jugent ils sont
exigeants pour l'éducation est une
affaire
sérieuse le livret scolaire d'olivier
est un modèle du genre ses professeurs
s'inclinent devant son application son
sérieux et ses
[Musique]
résultats plusieur réunions sur
l'orientation comment se passe la
seconde auoku et à partir de ça qu' on a
pu choisir on a pu on a pu voir un peu
plus tard j'père faire une école de
commerce quelque chose comme ça pour le
préfet des études la règle est simple le
kouu accueille tous ceux qui se
présentent dans la limite des places pas
de traitement de faveur pour leseff en
thème tous les élèves sont logé à la
même enseigne bon c'est vrai que dans la
mesure du possible on les pousse vers
des cycles long ça c'est sûr de toute
façon c'estattente des des familles bon
c'est ce qu'on souhaite aussi don y a
pas il y a pas de doute mais ceci dit
j'allais dire que on essaie de prendre
l'élève là où il est de tenir compte de
de la réalité qu'il vit et
essentiellement la réalité scolaire bon
qui est le point de départ et de le
mener un peu plus un peu plus
loin Sylvie dans son collège de
belleevue a quelques
inquiétudes pour avenir j'aimerais
j'aimerais mieux être plus
encadré là je passe
mais
avant ce que
cétait je CIS qu'on a été mal
informé pas
plus qui la faute nous avons rencontré
la directrice du collège nous avons
parlé
d'orientationorientation de éèes
l'orientation qu'est- que c'est pour
vous
non mais sans rire j'arrête là qu'est-ce
que vous entendez excusez-moi parce
qu'on s'ent quand même sur qu'est-ce que
c'est l'orientation pour
vous éidment inquiétant et lu que dans
cette salle du conseil de classe son
avenir va se jouer au moment de la
mystérieuse orientation sa grande peur
aller dans un lycée d'enseignement
professionnel considér pour les
nul on les
mavaisemenireire
Prs ventème larice du collège a son
point de vue sur la valeur des
diplômes l'économie n'a plus besoin des
gens il faut une formation plus pouss
l'économie besoin g au minimum peuesser
faire on ESS quand même à toute force
même si on tra des boul quelquefis qui
ne sont pas qui ser
jamais collège belleevue ou ceux du
collège du kaouou ont presque les mêmes
élèves les élèves du kaouzu ou de
belleevue ont presque les mêmes profs
pourtant ce n'est pas la même école et
ce n'est sans doute pas un crucifi dans
la salle à manger des Jésuites qui est
responsable de
tout il faut bien croire qu'il y a autre
chose d'ailleurs toutes les écoles
privées ne sont pas
confessionnelles il y a dans cette
maison un recrutement qui est certes qui
reste en majorité privilégié en ce sens
que les parents ont la possibilité de
choisir leur école donc c'est un
privilège je dirais peut-être culturel
mais les situations sont beaucoup plus
variés que peut-être vous ne le pensez
école privée école d'élite ou école
publique école d'élite quelle importance
Olivier et Sylvie se ressemble beaucoup
alors même que leurs écoles se
ressemblent si peu monsieur chevenemand
a dit que l'école de la République doit
être l'école de l'élite ben oui mais
nous sommes aussi dans la même
République ici que dans les autres
écoles françaises alors le problème il
est d'arriver à ce que quelle que soit
l'école qu'elle soit publique ou privée
arriver à ce que les enfants qui sont
confiés à ces écoles effectivement
puissent se réaliser pleinement et la
nation a besoin effectivement qu'il y
ait des
élites je suis assez d'accord en tout
cas pour dire qu'il faut assurer la
promotion de tous mais que notre pays a
besoin aussi
[Musique]
d'élite
ç la
visite ce sont des élèves instituteurs
s'ils savent chanter ils ne chantent pas
n'importe quoi et surtout pas n'importe
quand même si on le leur
demande car elle cassera jusqu'à son
dernier plat car elle cassera jusqu'à
son dernier plat car elle placera
jusqu'à son dernier PL Exell
merci en fait je voulais vous demander
aussi autre chose vous êtes au courant
que à partir de l'année prochaine
chevenenement a décidé qu'on allit
enseigner la Marseillaise vous vous êtes
on pas temps de la répéter vous êtes je
suppose que vous devez être un petit peu
cour vous savez comment elle se chante
non
non voulez pas chanter la Marise non non
euh on préfère vous chanter on préfère
vous chanter des chansons plus poétiques
parce que dans la Marseillaise il y a
quand même marchand Vengeons des des
mots méchants comme cela on a un sang
impur on préfère vous chanter des choses
très jolie à la sain Médard par exemple
il pleut les amoureux se retrouvent ils
se font des bisous vous préférez pas les
bisous au coup de couteau c'est
chevenénement qui a décidé c'est pas moi
qui a décidé qu'on allait faire chanter
ça écoutez chevenénement il est là-haut
nous nous sommes en bas c'est la base et
la base on préfère les bisous que les
coups de couteau je
crois non franchement ça nous est
délicat de vous la chanter je peux vous
jouer une Marseillaise que les élèves
que j'ai dans d'autres classe préfère
mais qu'il préfèrent une certaine
période c'est une autre marseillaise il
y a pas de de marseillaise il y a pas de
parole hein si vous voulez je peux vous
la jouer très rapidement mais vous allez
la reconnaître parce qu'elle est très
facile c'est ceci ce sont des élèves
quand même assez jeunes qui aiment ceci
vous
connaissez vous voulez
chanter ils connaissent mieux
voyez ils vont s'adresser à des
[Musique]
enfants cette chanson était quand même
écologique mon beau sapin nous cherchons
à protéger la nature plutôt que à nous
battre entre
[Musique]
nous